there are thousands upon thousands of
Hindu temples in India this one is
special because in many ways it is
emblematic of how polarized the country
has become under prime minister Narendra
Modi and it is at the heart of his
reelection
efforts it has been 3 years since the
ground was broken on the ram Temple here
in aoda but the history of the site is a
lot longer and more complicated than
those numbers
suggest as India prepares for a national
election the structure on the banks of
the river sarayu shows how modi's btia J
party has become a seemingly Unstoppable
electoral machine and it could help mod
fundamentally change the world's most
populous country
[Music]
construction here in aoda is
nonstop as thousands of workers race to
complete the temple the city in Northern
India has become one of the most popular
Hindu pilgrimage destinations and it has
a significance dating back thousands of
years that is when ancient scripture
started citing it as the birthplace of
ram in Hinduism Rah is one of the most
widely woried deities he's a hero of one
of the religions two epics the
ramayana born a prince of aoda the tale
recounts his Exile and then his victory
over the forces of evil he's seen as the
embodiment of all that is good the ideal
man for all those reasons and more it is
a convenient Association for the Prime
[Music]
Minister Modi has become India's most
powerful leader in decades by pushing
Hindu nationalism or Hindu it is a
strand of politics that conflicts Hindu
religious identity and policy and it
seeks to move India away from the
secular politics of its past instead
forging a nation for the majority Hindu
population aoda has become a
controversial focus of Hindu
nationalism for the best part of 500
years the temple was the site of a
mosque the barbre Masjid in
1992 thousands of Hindus overwhelmed
Security Forces to demolish the mosque
it was a political earthquake that saw
thousands die in the riots that followed
the quest to build a new Temple
galvanized the Hindu nationalist
movement and helped modi's rise to power
in his 2014 election campaign he made a
number of promises to crack down on
corruption develop the economy into
introduce the uniform civil code and the
autonomy of India's only Muslim majority
State Jammu and Kashmir and
significantly build the ram
[Music]
Temple but the last decade in power has
been challenging at time dies even as
India's economy continues to grow at a
rapid rate that growth hasn't benefited
everyone uniformly and unemployment
remains stubbornly High Modi has
delivered on some of his more
contentious promises scrapping kashmir's
autonomy and now building this
Temple these are policies that have
helped Modi overcome other electoral
concerns take the most recent elections
in November when key bellweather States
including madhia Pradesh Rajasthan and
chattis gar went to the polls opposition
leader Rahul Gandhi and his Indian
National Congress party had been hopeful
of capitalizing on some of modi's
perceived weaknesses to make indres
there was a sense before the vote that
support among farmers and women two of
the bjp's core constituencies
might be
[Music]
waning Patel is a former school teacher
who's now a homemaker after years voting
for The PJP she voted for Gandhi's
Indian National Congress in
November
Patel was particularly worried about
inflation which remained high in
November for about 70% of India's rural
households agriculture is still the sole
livelihood Modi promised to double farm
income when seeking his second term
tulsiram parar owns a large farm around
Bal
even so it has taken time for parar to
come around to Gandhi and the
[Music]
Congress desite the concerns there was
still a high turnout for
Modi when the election results landed on
December 3rd the BJP retained power in
madhia Pradesh and rested control of the
state legislature from the Indian
National Congress in both Rajasthan and
chattis gar the opposition political
parties despite their best efforts have
not been able to challenge or question
Mod's credibility in the eyes of the
people this is something which Rahul
Gandhi never understood that holding a
position of power or holding a state
office has a natural tendency of
introducing a Charisma in you and which
has benefited Narendra Modi in building
up his profile as concerns about
unemployment and Corruption persist in
some quarters the Indian Prime Minister
has taken advantage of rising
nationalism which is all Al taken hold
in other parts of the world and the ram
Temple stands as an example of that
prakash Sharma is a former leader of the
Hindu nationalist vhp the organization
that convened the rally with the BJP
that culminated in the destruction of
the babri Masjid in
[Music]
that Modi represents the interest of all
Hindus is of course hotly contested by
his opponents not least Rahul Gandhi
there's nothing Hindu about what the BJP
does they're not Hindu nationalists they
are nothing to do with Hinduism since we
are in a transition period from the
old-fashioned secular politics itics to
a majoritarian politics there are a lot
of people who are sympathizers and
supporters of the old ways they are very
disturbed by this politics of
polarization they think that that
something fundamentally disruptive is
being Unleashed by the present regime
the temple won't be completed for a few
years and yet Modi is opening it in
January 2024 This months before a
general
election an electoral Victory might let
his government pursue an agenda that
could include more temples on disputed
sides a national register of citizens
and a law that makes it harder for
Muslims to demonstrate that they are
Indian citizens steps that could cement
India's move away from the secular
politics of its
past
[Music]